[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an episode called good
boy from a horror anthology into the
dark
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
maggie glenn is a reporter based in los
angeles she is in her mid-30s and has
recently broken up with her boyfriend of
many years at the beginning of the movie
maggie is in a restaurant patiently
waiting for her date she is nervous
because she has not been on a blind date
since college the date goes well until
she asks the man about his thoughts on
kids he awkwardly says that he hasn't
thought about it yet he gets distant
after the question and barely talks to
her following the horrible date maggie
returns home and starts looking for
someone else on the dating site she
receives a message from a guy named nick
but ignores it the next day at work she
calls a fertility clinic and makes an
appointment since she is about to turn
40 maggie wants to freeze her eggs as an
extra measure to ensure she can get
pregnant in the future she meets dr
linda who runs several tests on her to
see if her eggs are suitable for
preservation maggie knows that the
process is very expensive but she hopes
to get promoted at work very soon
however her plan goes in vain when her
boss dawn announces their newspaper
company is going digital this would mean
that all the employees are getting laid
off to keep them motivated don claims
that they will get to work from home and
will still get paid if they bring in
traffic to the website however the pay
is very low and not definite maggie has
been working in the company for the past
12 years and doesn't know what she will
do without the job she gets a call from
the clinic informing her that she is
eligible for the ivf program she is
delighted but knows that without the
promotion she will never be able to
afford the procedure her boss dawn who
is also her good friend senses her
anxiety and suggests she get an
emotional support dog she takes it into
consideration and goes to a dog shelter
although she had decided to just take a
look at the options when she lays her
eyes on a tiny grey dog she instantly
knows that he has to come home with her
the shelter's employee reveals that the
dog's previous owner went to jail and he
was found by the police maggie brings
the dog home and buys him toys at night
she makes herself a reuben sandwich and
keeps it on the kitchen counter to her
surprise the tiny dog somehow jumps on
the counter and eats her sandwich in
seconds maggie laughs it off and names
the dog ruben like the sandwich
starting that day she brings him
everywhere she goes and takes great care
of the dog reuben helps her with her
anxiety like her boss had predicted one
day while they're on a walk maggie
notices a vacancy announcement at a
local coffee shop she starts working
there as a barista for extra money at
work maggie meets annie powell a girl
who she used to babysit when she was in
high school seeing that annie is already
engaged and has a huge social media
following makes her feel worse about her
life than she already did the girls
share their instagram handles and decide
to meet again someday when maggie
returns home that day a ball rolls
towards her from under the sofa thinking
that reuben wants to play she uses a
rope toy to bring him outside reuben
from the other side pulls the rope so
hard that she barely manages to keep up
to her horror reuben has also left nasty
scratches on the front door she figures
he might be missing her and dismisses
the matter
that night before going to bed she goes
through annie's instagram while
complaining about her life to the dog
she texts back a guy named nick from the
dating app and arranges a date with him
the following evening she and reuben go
to nick's mansion at first maggie is
impressed by the size of his house but
she soon finds out that it doesn't
belong to him nick starts getting closer
to her making her uncomfortable reuben
seems to sense her anxiety maggie
excuses herself and goes to the washroom
while nick steps out of the house to
smoke he hears rustling from a bush and
gets closer to inspect it when maggie
comes out looking for reuben she finds
him bloodied by the side of the road to
her horror nick's deformed dead body
lies nearby a neighbor calls the police
thinking that nick might have been hit
by a vehicle the next day maggie takes
the dog to the vet who runs some tests
on him and claims that he is perfectly
fine the blood on his fur might have
been splattered on him from being too
close when the accident occurred she
also takes his blood as a standard
protocol for all dogs first time at the
vet at home dawn calls her to tell that
the story she covered about nick's death
is the first hit of their website maggie
jumps in excitement when she is informed
that one more hit story will ensure she
gets a bonus that weekend annie and
maggie go to a yoga class together all
the other dogs in the class bark at
ruben for no apparent reason on
returning home bs sees ruben for the
first time and disapproves of him being
in her house maggie persuades her to let
her keep the dog promising to keep him
inside a cage most of the time reuben
senses that bia is making maggie anxious
and barks at her later she puts him in a
cage to go to work a while later bia is
in her bathroom when reuben appears
there out of the blue at work maggie
meets a friendly customer named nate he
leaves her his number on the back of the
receipt upon returning home she sees
that the dog has somehow escaped from
the cage and scratched a hole in the
window at the same time she gets a call
from ruben's doctor who says that his
blood test results came out abnormal so
they want to draw his blood again after
the call maggie enters bia's apartment
and finds her mauled dead body in the
bathtub a horrified maggie tries calling
the police but notices dog's excreta on
the floor and the broken window she puts
two and two together and realizes that
ruben has killed bia she soon registers
no one would believe that her tiny dog
could kill if people find out they would
probably suspect her of the murder still
maggie isn't mad at her dog instead she
holds him tight and assures him that
everything will be all right maggie is
starting to seem like a psychopath
following that she cleans up the mess
and wraps up via's body she drives it to
the countryside and buries her after
returning home she buys ruben an even
bigger cage to ensure he stays inside
she totally ignores what happened and
goes on with her life normally one day
while sunbathing by the side of the pool
she is approached by bia's niece elena
who asks her about her aunt maggie
calmly tells her that she hasn't seen
her in a few days a police officer
arrives to investigate the disappearance
to maggie's surprise the guy is nate the
customer who had given her his number
that evening they meet for a date at a
restaurant the two seem to have a lot in
common maggie also finds out that having
kids one day is on nate's bucket list
they enjoy each other's company and
decide to go out again sometime maggie
writes about bia's disappearance on the
website and gets more traffic than ever
dawn texts her saying she has just
confirmed her bonus after finding that
out she goes to the fertility clinic
once again to go forward with the ivf
procedure she happily returns home that
day but soon finds out that her work
bonus is only two hundred dollars she
goes to don's office and confronts him
about the pay they get into a huge
argument which ends when don fires her
from the job
don is a verifiable piece of crap she
brings her belongings to the car along
with reuben when suddenly the dog runs
back up before maggie can get to him she
sees dawn being attacked by reuben
through the window she quickly rushes to
don's room and sees his bloodied dead
body instead of freaking out she calls
reuben a good boy following that she
throws dawn's body off the building to
make it seem like a case of suicide she
calmly brings reuben home and cleans him
up after dawn's death maggie gets
promoted to his position in the company
she now has a good job a loving
boyfriend and a backup plan if she can't
have a baby it's truly amazing the
things that becoming a serial killer can
do for you that evening annie nate and
her friends go to a bar to celebrate
maggie's promotion they also bring ruben
because maggie is too scared to leave
him on his own one day at work a
policeman comes to see maggie to inquire
about next hit-and-run case he asks her
why she was at the location of the
accident to which she claims that she
was there to walk her dog the policeman
suspects her story but has no evidence
to prove her wrong in the meantime she
continues visiting the fertility clinic
the procedure causes bruises on her arms
and legs as a side effect at night nate
comes over to her house with a dog cam
as a gift he has hardly been able to
spend time with her because she always
has to return home to the dog hence he
believes the dog cam will help her with
her anxiety when she is away from ruben
maggie thanks him and sets up the cam
near reuben's cage following that they
walk to nate's house while enjoying cups
of ice cream a man bumps into them and
walks away without apologizing maggie
shouts profanities at him surprising
nate he calms her down and brings her to
get another cup of ice cream in the
following scene they are in nate's bed
but maggie is too worried about ruben to
focus on him she checks on him through
the camera but is still unsatisfied on
returning home the next morning she sees
some policemen arresting elena who had
been living in bia's apartment they
believe that she is involved in her
aunt's disappearance maggie quickly gets
inside her apartment to see reuben has
trashed it completely
later she and nate are hanging out by
the pool talking about bia's case nate
is unsettled by maggie's intrusiveness
about the case he asks her regarding the
bruises on her hands suspecting that she
is doing drugs maggie tells him about
the ivf procedure she has the final egg
removal the following day so nate offers
to drive her to the clinic during the
process maggie is given anesthetic drugs
that make her hallucinate she dreams of
the doctor confronting her about all the
murders she tries to get free but cannot
because her hands are bound to the bed
after the process nate drives her home
since she is too weak to do it on her
own at night he is working late so annie
comes over to keep her company she tells
maggie that her husband is forcing her
to try for a baby back in the police
station nate's superior tells him about
the prints that were found in three
crime scenes including in bia's
apartment when he finds out that dawn's
crime scene also had the same prince he
starts to suspect maggie he calls her to
tell her about the prince maggie freaks
out and asks annie to cut the phone call
annie tries to reassure her that the
prince just mean the killer will be
found quicker ruben mistakes annie for
making maggie anxious and attacks her he
somehow grows into a beast and drags her
into the sofa maggie tries her best to
save annie but is unsuccessful after her
death she has no option but to clean the
house and get rid of the body she drives
to the countryside and buries her dead
body not wanting to keep doing this
anymore she drives away leaving reuben
by the side of the road in the meantime
nate goes through footage from reuben's
dog cam and finds maggie dragging annie
through the door when maggie reaches
home he confronts her about the murders
and handcuffs her just then the
transformed reuben barges in and attacks
nate killing him at last a while later
policemen arrive at the house and arrest
maggie for the murders in the final
scene we see reuben in the dog shelter
yet again the employee introduces him to
a man who presumably brings him home
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching